As operating system designers, the natural question
that comes up is, okay, all this sounds
good. But do I lose out on
performance for the convenience of component-based design? This
is the same question that came up when we wanted to go for a microkernel-based
design, away from a monolithic design of
an operating system. The Cornell experiment takes it
one step further and argues for
synthesizing individual subsystems of an operating system
from modular components. Just like putting
together lego blocks to get the desired
functionality. I encourage you to read the paper from Cornell in full. That
shows that this methodology, applied to
one specific subsystem, results in a performance
competitive implementation of the protocol
stack, compared to a monolithic implementation.